Manor Sees at least 30 patients a day a
district nurse in Northwestern France
she says she enjoys the job but is
physically and mentally exhausting with
long hours and low pay
son I drive around 100 kilometers but
some colleagues in the countryside can
drive up to 300 a day the French
governments raise the minimum retirement
age by two years to 64 for workers born
after 1968 but many people will have to
work Beyond 64 to fulfill the required
criteria that includes working at least
43 years and for Mano that means
retiring at 67 stopping work earlier
would mean losing two-thirds of her
pension
I can't see myself lifting people out of
beds carrying them I can't imagine
people doing this job at 67 we are asked
to care for people but no one cares for
us
French president Emmanuel macro says
France's pension system needed to change
to save money and reflect the fact that
people are living longer most people
realize they'll have to work a little
longer on average because otherwise we
won't be able to finance our pensions
properly
some in France disagree and say it's
unfair months of protests and Strikes
earlier this year cause disruption and
at times led to violence the French
government's decision to force a bill
through Parliament by decree only made
things worse
forcing the reform is not Democratic
we're angry macron doesn't listen to us
French president Emmanuel macro has
fulfilled one of his campaign Promises
by pushing through the pension reform
but it's come at a cost the pension
reform has left a legacy which is very
difficult to Bear for the president is
tries to do as if it doesn't exist but
the problem is still lingering and the
fact is now is government is very much
anchored on the right side of the
political Spectrum so he has lost the
left and the more time passes the more
he's on the right macros government
wants to forge ahead with more reforms
including on immigration but it doesn't
have a parliamentary majority this week
the president met opposition Party
leaders in a rare attempt to build
Bridges whether it'll work remains to be
seen anger is still simmering over the
pension law the next months could be
challenging Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
Georges Northwestern France
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera